for fans of the Pokemon series detective
Pikachu is filled with plenty of playful
nods to the wider Pokemon universe but
some of these small references are all
too easy to miss to help you keep track
here are a few of the finer details that
may have snuck past you whoever you are
uses in the film we learned that the
menacing Pokemon known as Mewtwo was
captured before the events of Detective
Pikachu and I was able to escape human
captivity 20 years prior to the events
in the film this is likely an allusion
to the first Pokemon film appropriately
titled Pokemon the first movie which
made its North American premiere in
November of 1999 the first movie centers
around Mewtwo's origin story beginning
with its creation in a lab on new island
eventually Mewtwo escapes and
subsequently destroys the entire lab in
his rage but by the end of the film it's
shown that not all humans are bad though
detective Pikachu doesn't focus
primarily on Mewtwo and its origin the
parallels are clear Mewtwo is similarly
captured experimented on and
subsequently escapes in the film though
it comes to believe that humans aren't
inherently evil hey isn't that a
Jigglypuff you're right Brock it's a
Ghibli puff
throughout the Pokemon universe
Jigglypuff is known for its ability to
low people and other Pokemon to sleep
when it seems in the animated series
Jigglypuff singing is often used as a
joke that inconveniences the main
characters and makes them fear this
balloon like Pokemon whenever it appears
in several episodes the Pokemon performs
for the main characters only for them to
inevitably fall asleep upset that no one
listens to it song Jigglypuff becomes
angry and draws ridiculous images on the
faces of its sleeping audience
Jigglypuff makes a brief appearance and
detective Pikachu when Tim and Pikachu
visit a cafe you get to see a Jigglypuff
sing to another patron as he sleeps on
the table just as in the enemy
Jigglypuff puffs up visibly upset that
its song is being ignored a known or
unique Pokemon that resembled a Latin
alphabet no one feels really high the
Pokemon species has 28 total different
forms and with so many different
variations it's not surprising that at
least one would make it into the film
while an actual unknown never makes an
appearance in detective Pikachu they do
pop up on Tim's t-shirts as a loving
visual tribute even though let's face it
unknown are more than faintly terrifying
in many of the Pokemon games a common
roadblock is a giant Snorlax sleeping in
the middle of the road these giant
Pokemon require a special polka flute to
awaken them resulting in the player
going on a quest for the item before
being able to progress to a new area in
the game
Snorlax has also appeared in the Pokemon
anime as well notably in the episode
wake up Snorlax
it's a Snorlax that's a Snorlax oh right
in that particular episode a sleeping
Snorlax locks a water source from
flowing into a nearby town needless to
say Snorlax has been an obstacle
throughout Pokemon and this trend of
Snorlax inconveniently blocking roads
continues and detective Pikachu in one
particular shot after Tim first arrives
in Rhyme City a Snorlax can be seen
sleeping in the road as drivers try to
navigate around it
while the Snorlax is only shown briefly
its inclusion is a fun callback that's
sure to appeal to fans an early episode
of Pokemon the series entitled here
comes the squirtle squad a group of
mischievous squirtles play pranks on
passers-by going so far as to dig
pitfalls for unsuspecting travelers to
fall into eventually the group of
squirtles come to see the error of their
ways and give up these wild antics
[Music]
quite a flannel later on in the episode
the firing squad
the squirtles diligently work with
firefighters in an official capacity and
even participate in a firefighting
competition squirtles are seen a few
times in detective Pikachu why there's
one right here on this missing poster
elsewhere in the film we see a group of
squirtles dutifully working with
firefighters from rhyme city and putting
out fires left and right we're glad to
see they're still out there fighting the
good fight check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]